everybody needs to do like president
Hagan and they need to start a
scholarship George all universities need
to start a George Floyd scholarship for
black students do exactly like President
Reagan did here at northcentral
University and that's exactly what needs
to happen you know what man is not is
not about me I think it's more about
just standing with the family you know
in a moment like this just literally
letting them know that they're not alone
we've now we now have a job to do which
is elevate our voices use our platforms
and really push the initiative for
change so you know for me it was a
no-brainer just to come more importantly
man when you just look at what's going
on globally and you look at you look at
the many different voices that are now
being used and people aligning
themselves you make your point to be a
part of it be a part of a mission that's
for good and I think that right now is
not only time for change but I think
that it's it's it's happening you know
there's a there's a positive and every
negative and I think there's gonna be an
amazing positive to come out of this you
have to help lead the way absolutely man
so once again my condolences go to the
family and you know to all lives that
were lost through these senseless deaths
like this I think it's our time it's our
service to simply uplift that's what I'm
doing what did it mean to be here today
and how important was it it's painful
unfortunately as a black man we've been
in these rooms way too many times
and God has given us all a platform a
stage influence whatever level of
comfort whatever level of reassurance
whatever level of just being fully
present and whatever comfort ability we
have contributed to you on any level of
just being here that's what we wanted to
do this is pain the pain is going to
turn a lot of benefits for a lot of
future generations to come
action about as militant as it gets I'm
just waiting on my marching orders I got
him to be here I just want to send my
most sincere prayers and I just hope the
family invite the Lord Jesus Christ in
their most vulnerable space because only
he could give them a level of security
and stand with them yeah
this is this this all hurts my this is a
very very painful thing god bless you